this week in our series on the new
normal we look at how
panda pandemic is dramatically changing
our everyday lives
those changes will affect the way we
work socialize
learn and vote many of us have many of
us have been under stay at home orders
for more than a month now
and while the way we interact with
family and friends is different
those connections have become critical
for our mental health
psychologist and cbs news contributor
lisa demour joins us now from her home
in cleveland as we begin mental health
awareness month
lisa good morning i want to start with
this i was looking at a university of
chicago poll last night that said
two-thirds of americans say they felt
nervous depressed
lonely or hopeless in just the last week
and i gotta believe that's
in part because we're it's so difficult
to connect with people now how is
the pandemic changing the way we
interact with people socially
well it's true you know we're really
unplugged from our normal social support
all of the people that help support us
in the day to day you know our friends
at work the people we run into at the
coffee shop
they are not part of our daily lives
anymore
and what i am seeing is that people have
activated what i call their backup
social system generators
old friends reaching out to people they
haven't been in touch with for a long
time
and i think it's a sort of really
fascinating thing to watch happen as we
lose our day-to-day support to sort of
dig back into those
relationships that have been really
valuable and really powerful for us
and to lean on those and i know there's
some worried that there might be some
hard feelings like why are you only in
touch with me now and are we going to
stay in touch later
but i actually think we should take it
as an honor to be somebody's backup
social system and to be theirs
you say these connections are more
important than ever now
i think they are i think that when times
are disrupted we get pretty
philosophical about things
and i think that when we reach out to
people we've been close with
at other times in our lives it's our way
of letting them know like you hold a
really special place in my heart and i'm
reminded of that now especially
well lisa i haven't left my apartment
since march 31st i'm literally talking
to the birds outside the window on the
27th floor so i really look forward to
the
social reconnection part so what does
that look like to you
well i think it'll be different for
different people because i think we've
been in touch with people at different
levels
a lot of us have folks who are in our
everyday traffic pattern
that matter to us but we're not so close
that we've been in touch over this time
so i think some people may be feeling
anxious about that and seeing those
people again
and what i would say is you know drop
them a text drop them an email
that says oh i can't wait till i can
stop by your desk again or something
like that
our friendships are context dependent
and when we're back in those contexts
they work well
what's your advice for people who are
struggling with social distancing
you know this is a hard time some people
are very very lonely
some people are surrounded by people
they can't get
much space from but those people aren't
giving them the social support they need
so what i would say is that you should
reach out if you're feeling lonely
that there's no one right way to have
support some people need lots
some people just need one really
powerful connection but i would want
people to really
tend to their social needs in the same
way they would tend to a physical health
need to really take good care of
themselves
lisa i think a lot of people some of
what they're feeling it's not even
conscious you know what i mean it's like
under the surface
and it's hard to identify uh how do you
how do you know
when you're sort of in a in trouble in a
moment like this
you know i would worry if a person were
falling back on what i would call
negative coping strategies you know
whether they're maybe
totally holding up and not contacting
anyone
or turning to substances as a way to
manage emotional discomfort
or you know not getting out of bed or
being really cranky with the people
around them
i would say if we see those kinds of
patterns i would really want people
to get help and sometimes they may get
help from people around them
the other thing that's really important
is that if you don't have the social
support you need and you need mental
health care
you can almost certainly get that now
telehealth appointments are now widely
available
from mental health clinicians just as
they are now becoming wildly available
from physical health clinicians
what do you think we should remember
during this time i say thank goodness
for the zoom zoom i call
it and facetime and skype that we can
physically see people that we're
separated from
but what it's not the same but what do
we need to remember during this time
i think we need to remember how
important people are to us the other
thing i want people to bear in mind is
if you haven't heard from somebody in
this time
i don't want you to make assumptions
about what this is about
people are going through a lot some
people may be dealing with very
difficult losses
so if you think like why haven't i heard
from that person where have they been
i think we should always give people the
benefit of the doubt at times like this
they're really doing their best and
there may be more going on than you
know and so as we reconnect with people
we haven't heard from
i think we don't want to do anything
that suggests that we somehow take it
personally
that we haven't heard from them yeah
yeah everyone's struggling through this
time in some way lisa demour thank you
so much
for being with us this morning